an update tonight on a deadly crash a
newsdown reported on this on tuesday a
43 year old tara russell sitting in jail
right now on charges she was driving
under the influence when she was
involved in a crash that took the life
of 65 year old debbie bass happened
tuesday morning at sahara and rainville
and that is where we find our joe
moeller with additional charges russell
faces joe
debbie bass was a passenger in that
vehicle her husband patrick bass was the
driver and he was also seriously hurt
tara russell not only
facing charges of dui but also reckless
driving and running a red light that
crash that happened here is now serving
as a warning to watch your speed and to
not drink and drive
we're actually pretty busy that morning
carlo paredes owned smash iron fitness
at saharan rainbow i was trying to get
into work at 6 00 a.m
and there was just a lot of already a
lot of traffic as he approached work he
also saw that intersection of saharan
rainbow closed he says crashes like the
one that happened here around 1 in the
morning is a worry for his 24-hour gym
i'm totally concerned
i see the markings on the road now and
i'm really concerned on what happened
according to the arrest report for 43
year old tara russell police say she was
traveling at a high rate of speed on
sahara when her buick hit a hyundai on
rainbow inside patrick and debbie bass
the police report states witness
information and video from the nearby
7-eleven showed russell ran a red light
so the roads are going to be crowded and
we all have the responsibility to be out
there and driving safe sergio avila from
aaa says 109 million people will be
hitting the road for christmas police
say russell admitted to smoking
marijuana and a witness saw a beer can
in russell's car a reminder that crashes
like these are avoidable if you're going
to be drinking have a plan
either get ride share or have a
designated driver
back out here live russell will remain
in jail for now as she returns to court
on monday meanwhile the bass family is
now dealing with the loss of a loved one
on this holiday reporting live this
evening joe muller live local now